he's led the country for more than 30
years
and now seeking a sixth term incumbent
idris debbie cast his vote in chad's
presidential election
urging other charities in the capital
and around the country to do the same
i have come here today as a citizen to
vote
and have done my duty now it's your turn
the people of chad to exercise your
right to vote
wherever you are come and vote for the
candidate of your choice
hundreds were waiting to vote at the
same center where debbie appeared
twenty-three-year-old amina ahmed a
first-time voter
was one of the first in the queue
i've come to exercise democracy and also
to see the president
marshall debbie is the one i think will
be able to lead the country forward
and bring it stability and improve the
economy here's the only one i see in the
field
7.3 million people have registered to
vote in this election
according to the national electoral
commission many voters we spoken to on
sunday and in the days leading up to the
election
say their biggest concern is chad
stability and security
after a civil war in the east and recent
counterterrorism operations in the north
and west
many tell us they believe president
debbie who's running against five other
candidates can tackle those issues
the candidates need at least 52 percent
of the vote to win
the results will be out in two weeks the
opposition and their supporters say they
are boycotting the elections
six prominent figures who sought to run
for president were rejected by the high
court
two accused the ruling party of
militarizing the campaign
a charge echoed by right groups who say
security forces have used ruthless force
against protesters and opposition
leaders
we don't think there is transparency
there is a
freedom so that's why we can't accept
this election
and we call people to buy caught it
until
the end of this theater election
observers appear to have a different
view
chad's role is important in the region
especially in lake chad and the sahel
saharan region so preserving its
stability
is the role of the african countries and
the region
and the people of the country whatever
the outcome of this election
the gap between debbie's ruling party
and the opposition is clear
how the two sides move on from here will
almost certainly set the stage
for the country's political future hiba
morgan al jazeera
jamaina chad